Buenas tardes es una vez visita bien
simbólica porque el Reino Unido ha sido
uno de los grandes aliados de Ucrania
desde que inició la invasión rusa hace
casi un año pero es sobre todo la manera
en que el presidente selensky le dice al
mundo pero especialmente a Rusia no
tenemos miedo no tengo miedo Sí el
presidente ya está en territorio
británico se ha reunido por minutos con
el Primer Ministro Richie sunat donde
hablaron sobre el aumento del apoyo
militar que el Reino Unido dará Ucrania
y más adelante el presidente se dirigirá
al parlamento británico un beneficio que
pocos líderes internacionales han tenido
se lens que ya lo ha hecho vía virtual
en el 2022 pero es un discurso que será
bien bien importante posteriormente
tendrá una audiencia privada con el Rey
Carlos tercero que es el jefe de estado
británico Y luego el Primer Ministro
Richie sunak y el presidente es el
lensky viajarán a una base en Inglaterra
donde los militares ucra son entrenados
por las tropas británicas ahora Luisa lo
que nos preguntamos es si el Reino Unido
aprobara más ayuda para Ucrania
definitivamente hasta el momento el
Reino Unido ha dado dos mil millones de
libras esterlinas en ayuda militará a
Ucrania y lo que se espera es que más
adelante hoy el Primer Ministro detalle
los planes para más ayuda en este caso
van a empezar a entrenar pilotos de
aviones de combate e infantes de Marina
Esto será un programa a largo plazo
según Downey Street estos pilotos van a
volar sofisticados aviones de combate
estándar de la otan en el futuro Pero
además el Reino Unido anunciará
inmediatamente el aumento de más apoyo
militar Tendremos que esperar para saber
cuáles son los detalles pero se ha
conocido además que en los últimos seis
meses alrededor de 30.000 militares
entre ellos 20 mil soldados han recibido
entrenamiento aquí en el Reino Unido por
parte de las tropas británicas